this is a wacky story it is now alleged
that for former current right-wing
provocateur Milo yiannopoulos who I
believe quote interned for Marjorie
Taylor green I mean every every element
of this story doesn't make any sense
Milo yiannopoulos is accused of stealing
Marjory Taylor Green's credit card
and using it to pay campaign expenses
for Kanye West's presidential campaign
which never really got going and if you
look into the details it actually seems
as though Milo used the credit card to
buy a domain which he was then
reimbursed for but then he was
reimbursed a bunch more money which
anytime you see that you start wondering
about money laundering it's a completely
Bonker story